come back everybody we finish off the
show with a story from the future where
the role of attorneys could change from
humans to artificial intelligence that's
right a startup revealed that its first
robot lawyer will go on a trial run in
February the concept was developed by do
not pay a startup company that uses AI
to provide legal advice CEO Joshua
Browder said the goal of the company was
to save defendants money by replacing
the physical lawyer and in an upcoming
case their Robo lawyer will be helping
an actual client fight a traffic ticket
the smartphone-based AI will listen to
arguments in court analyze them and then
instruct the defendant on a response the
defendant will then repeat only what
their Robo advisor feeds them through
headphones in court Browder says that if
they happen to lose the lawsuit don't
worry the company has agreed to cover
any fines associated with the case and
they're actually even taking it a step
further offering one million dollars to
anyone who argues a case in front of the
United States Supreme Court only saying
what the Raw lawyer dictates in addition
to providing court-based legal
assistance the company promises their ai
ai can help users quote fight
corporations beat bureaucracy and Sue
anyone at the Press of a button Brian
you are borrowed in scotus if we see you
arguing a case with air ponds on should
you expect you're at work afterwards I
actually just had to take off my airpods
now so I can answer this for myself uh
but I don't think any lawyer is going to
be doing this no one is going to
sacrifice their bar license it takes a
lot to get to the scotus bar or any bar
for that matter and I think one of the
justices regardless of what side of the
aisle they're on will probably stop this
I don't think this is going to get past
a traffic ticket in terms of use I don't
I think there's too much on the line
when you're talking about the Supreme
Court or even losing one day of your
Liberty maybe this might work in traffic
court but I hope this doesn't go on past
that Terry other than the fact that
robots are taking over in our whole
world is destroyed uh any problems with
this and lots of problems actually
Deloitte says that by 2036 a hundred
thousand legal jobs will be taken over
by AI so it is something we should all
think about but then again who could
present the way we're presenting here
Jesse but the other issue is this has
not even been determined by the Supreme
Court as to whether or not there's a
constitutional right to a real lawyer
using these AI intelligence lawyers I
don't think is going to help look the
pros are that you have unlimited
research and you have unlimited
intelligence and that is a pro but there
are so many cons to this what happens if
the Wi-Fi goes down what happens if the
client doesn't actually repeat what the
AI is telling them to say and just
mistakes a little bit of what he has to
say not a lot of it who's going to argue
that you know they should be reimbursed
because they said most of what was said
but not all of what was said and then
you know you have the Council on the
other side who could be objecting to the
fact that look you're being helped out
by artificial intelligence and it's not
fair I should have artificial
intelligence too I just see so many
problems with setting it up this way I
think at the end of the day though we
are going to see it in some aspects of
the legal profession I just don't think
they'll be able to make new arguments or
Equitable arguments so there's some
limitations there let's hope that they
uh you know don't make AI anchors
because then I'm going to be out of a
job and it'll probably do a better job
than I do so let's hope for that that
doesn't happen well let's see let's see
we'll see what they'll have this
conversation in 10 years Brian Terry
thanks so much everyone thanks for
joining us here on Long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
Justice in America
foreign